the real trick is making sure that both
those lines are level mine aren't hi
guys my name is Maddie Conrad and I'm
going to show you the four easy steps to
take care of your beard at home now I
know a lot of us are feeling a little
overgrown these days because we haven't
been able to go and see our barber to
take care of our beards and grooming
your beard can be a really tricky
procedure well I'm gonna show you just a
few easy ways that you can take care of
it at home that'll get you over the hump
step one is wash your beard now this is
a really important step because beards
gather a lot of bacteria is collect food
and all sorts of other things it's
really important especially right now to
keep your beard clean so choose a beard
cleanser that you can use every single
day something that's gentle and
something that is going to moisturize
the skin beneath the beard to prevent
flakiness now for those of you that are
quarantine with a partner my biggest
suggestion is take a towel and lay it
down over top of your sink this will
help you avoid all those little hairs
that gather and just make your partner
crazy
step two is detangling for this I like
to use a wide tooth pick because it puts
a lot less tension on the beard hair as
you run it through the beard you want to
keep going through until you feel no
more tension and no more pulling of the
beard once you've done that all the way
through you've gotten rid of all the
tangles and you're ready to move on to
step three step three is the interior
that's the bulk and the shape of the
beard for this we want to take our
adjustable Clipper and set it halfway
open which means you're going to move
the lever halfway between all the way
forward and all the way back turn it on
and take to Clipper upside down creating
a nice straight line working downwards
always working downwards with the beard
will help you preserve length if you
work upwards it's gonna grab the hair
and you're gonna take chunks working
downwards will make it smoother start
from the top near the sideburn and
create a wall straight down the side
just looking for the hairs that are
sticking out and flying away you want to
think of this area kind of like a wall
and make this nice and flat and smooth
once you've taken your first pass take a
brush and brush the hair down you'll
notice as you do this other additional
hairs pop out that you didn't get before
because they were tangled in the beard
do this two or three times and repeat
the process until the side is nice and
smooth
then you're going to repeat this on the
other side
once you've got the walls finished on
either side nice and flat and smooth
with no flyaways work very slightly
underneath the chin but be careful in
this area you don't want to remove too
much hair because this is where the bulk
of the beard is brush the hair down
slightly and just pick one single pass
over top underneath your mouth
[Music]
it looks better already the second part
of the interior is called the shelf and
that's the length of the beard
underneath this should have a slight
downward angle forward so it looks more
like a jaw shape what you want to do is
tilt your head back
take your Clipper inverted and punch a
straight line from the front length of
the beard right towards your Adam's
apple
[Music]
once you've done a single pass take your
pick and pull down any hairs that may be
tangled underneath
[Music]
and take a second pass to clean it up
[Music]
[Laughter]
this area underneath the neck will grow
hair your goal is to make sure that you
don't see any hair growing on the neck
behind the front line or the length of
the beard if you see hair growing down
here clean that up my suggestion is to
take your clipper first reverse it and
work upwards just softly on the neck
to pick the hair nice and short before
you shave it
this will make it much more comfortable
for you to remove with a razor or with
the trimmer now it's time for step four
which is the outline now the outline of
the beard is very important and it's
broken down into three steps the top
line the base line and the lip line
let's start with the top line to create
a strong top line you're trying to
create a nice clean line from the corner
of the sideburn towards the corner of
the mouth this line can either be
straight or it can be slightly curved
most people wear their lines slightly
curved but if you have a wider face
shape I suggest using a straight line
it'll make you look leaner take your
trimmer and turn it on invert it and
punch a line descending from the corner
of the sideburn toward the corner of the
MOU
[Music]
once you want to remove the hairs that
grow up in the cheeks turn your Clipper
over and push up away from that line
this gives your beard the appearance of
being thicker and stronger repeated on
the opposite side
the real trick is making sure that both
those lines are level mine aren't
much better the baseline is the bottom
part of the outline of the beard it
starts behind the ear and descends all
the way around the Adam's apple and up
the other side you want this to be as
clean and strong as possible start from
behind the ear making sure you hold the
bulk of the beard out of the way and
outline it using the trimmer delicately
pressing the line
now we have a nice line from the corner
of the jaw
descending towards the Adam's apple it's
easiest to just slip your head
carve in a nice straight line right at
the corner
[Music]
and work their way down towards the
Adam's apple
[Music]
now we're going to start on the opposite
side
[Music]
brush through your hair just to make
sure you got all the pieces and that
there aren't any additional flyways the
lip line which is the last step you want
to make sure that your mustache isn't
going over the crest of the mower so to
do that I like to call all of the hair
forward and I like to create something
that Peaks vary slightly in the center
for people that have short beards they
can follow the top lip line creating a
soft peak in the center using their
trimmer but for longer beards it's
better to create an arcing shape away to
the corner to do that turn your clipper
on its side
start in the center and roll outwards
towards the corner of the mouth
once you're all finished I highly
recommend applying beard oil to nourish
and moisturize the beard to apply a
beard oil just take two or three drops
and work it between the palms of your
hands apply it throughout the beard
vigorously so it gets all the way
through and coats all of the hair to
finish it off and make sure it gets all
the way through the beard use a natural
bristle brush natural bristles have a
tendency to move oil around in the hair
and will actually help you condition the
beard
[Music]
and there we have a perfectly groomed
longer beard so when it comes to growing
out of beard let's say you've never had
one before and you're looking at covet
quarantine as your opportunity to go for
it
a couple of steps need to happen first
of all you need to stop shaving you need
to see what's gonna grow in and how
thick some people have very dense growth
all over their face and some people have
very patchy areas that's okay because
not all beards need to look the same
there's lots of different types of
beards that you can pick if you have
very patchy cheeks or bald spots you may
want to consider going with something
lower maybe a goatee or simply dropping
the mustache because I think that's
cooler than people give it credence to
but if you are somebody that's trying a
beard out and has a full growth all over
I highly suggest just focusing on the
outline of the beard for the first two
to three months and letting the bulk of
the beard grow in the only area where
you may want to consider trimming it
down slightly is in the cheek area and
making sure the outline stays nice and
crisp from the corner of your jaw to the
top of your Adam's apple that's going to
give you the strongest beard shape and
give you a fighting chance at growing a
damn fine-looking beard good luck and
good grooming
[Music]